[Musique]
l'ensemble de la rédaction de ces news à
laquelle j'appartiens et qui est très
attaché au débat d'idées à la libre
expression de tous les courants de
pensée ne partage pas ces propos et ne
sont que l'expression de votre point de
vue est pas le point de vue de ses luxe
ils sont voleurs ils sont assassins ils
sont violeur c'est tout ce qu'ils sont
il faut les renvoyer
eric zemmour au sujet des mineurs isolés
accueillis en france ce matin elisabeth
moreno la mine ce délégué chargé de la
diversité de l'égalité a dénoncé une
nouvelle sortie abjecte et raciste
directement qui devra en répondre devant
la justice
c'est moi qui suis au nid c'est moi qui
suis critiqué c'est moi qui suis attaqué
en justice ce n'est ni la les réactions
de ces news ni d'autres personnes
donc je sais ce que c'est que la
responsabilité c'est un multirécidiviste
de la haine du racisme
condamné à plusieurs reprises lui qui
parle souvent de récidive d'ailleurs et
le message judicial ne l'a pas entendu
au lieu de s'en prendre à moi
le ministre de la justice devrait s'en
prendre à ces délinquants et aux risques
qu'ils déposaient sur les français sur
la sécurité des français
ta déversoir de haine moi j'étais
confronté à lui sur un plateau du parti
d'ailleurs son idée c'était que
l'immigration avait coûté cher à la
france
je suis parti je lui ai dit mon taxi
arabe matin je me suis levé je suis
parti je pense que jamais dans
l'histoire contemporaine la période n'a
été aussi injuste pour notre jeunesse
j'ai conscience des sacrifices qu'on lui
a demandé ces derniers mois et qu'on lui
demande encore on peut pas sortir de
cette crise en ayant juste plus de
dettes financières qu'on lui laissera
une dette climatique qu'on n'aura pas
réglé et une espèce de morosité qu'on va
lui laisser
il ne faut donc pas vous décourager si
vous voyez que
si vous voyez que la situation sanitaire
continue de se dégrader pendant quelques
jours dans votre territoire
alors que vous faites des efforts à
matignon depuis hier les rencontres
s'enchaînent
françois baroin président de
l'association des maires de france
reçus par jean castex et olivier vers
ans depuis la sortie de l'été il ya un
certain relâchement en général il ya
probablement eu un peu de relâchement de
la part de l'état dans sa représentation
locale comme dans ses prises de parole
publiques au cours de ces derniers jours
et ce matin le premier ministre s'est
entretenu avec les maires de paris lyon
toulouse grenoble et lille
l'horaire de fermeture des bars à 22h ne
nous semblait pas être appropriées
c'est une mesure que l'on juge devoir
être assouplie en échange bien sûr d'une
rigueur plus importante dans le respect
des protocoles sanitaires tout cas moi
je lance ce matin devant vous un message
d'alerté parce que plus personne n'y
comprend rien les français n'ont plus
confiance dans le gouvernement et ce qui
pose un problème parce que vous pouvez
appliquer décider des contraintes mais
pour que la contrainte soit correctement
appliquée il faut la confiance il n'y a
plus la confiance nouvelle et on va tout
faire
attention ça devient très grave donc
respectons les règles vous voulez une
primaire bien sûr parce que et vous êtes
pour que rachida et vous êtes candidat à
la primaire et bien je porterai mes
idées je voulais dit plusieurs fois oui
un jeune héros n'ont pas ri en sursis la
situation dans la capitale et ses abords
s'est encore dégradée la région
parisienne pourrait donc passer en état
d' alerte maximale dès lundi passage en
zone d' alerte maximale supposera que
les habitants de paris et de la petite
couronne réduit temporairement leurs
interactions sociales de manière
drastique en tout cas plus importantes
que ce qu'il font d'ores et déjà plus de
fêtes de famille plus de soirées
fermeture totale des barres la police
espagnols interceptent un voilier au
large de l'archipel des canaries
au total quatre bateaux vont faire
l'objet de fouilles
à l'intérieur les autorités découvrent
30 tonnes de haschich une saisie record
pour le pays